what's what's the relationship between
ego and white white go like this
give rasa so here are five is elbow can
you get up we can't get up she keeps
getting up right you can keep pulling it
out she's not gonna get up so I would
like you to understand
Niq your word the way we understand EQ
order so he's trying to get up right
that's what I'm doing this so he's
trying to get up again and I'm gonna
make a tighter space by doing it 10 Khan
even tighter
I don't leave his elbow around it coming
around well he gets up and I'm gonna
beat here so if you go back I'm right
here
I'm not I'm not over here like this okay
cuz that's EQ oh hi
so I leave his elbow where it is and I
move inside and bring his arm then when
he comes around and puts the nikkyo on
himself
you see that then when I finish it and
what I finish it I'm gonna make eight
even tighter circle so he's going to go
around
do you see that and there is the pin
he's trying to get up lead him around he
tries to get up tighter circle and he
puts to me young himself then don't come
here in other words
trying to get up he tries to get up put
it on himself then this goes tight boom
and you're in it
do you see how I did that then we'll go
back right here
okay he tries to get up you put it on
and stop and I'm gonna make a even
tighter circle boom because my hips turn
but my body doesn't move and I end up
here so don't don't make don't make your
your knee kyo look like on board with
eat yo i'm going to kill that's what you
guys are like right hey you have you
killed then you go ah let's do this oh
let me flip it over it makes no sense
not tactically not conceptually you
understand that so instead I'm just
working with these circles boom
okay
so remember the concept that that he
throws himself that's what I'm working
with here so when he tries to stand up
when I do that you see he throws himself
okay because of because of where I lead
his elbow so put your leg up he's trying
to stand up but this isn't where his
elbow is right his elbows going to be
over here so when he tries to stand up
it makes him makes it balanced but
outside of his base of support okay so
that so that's what we're doing in eto
dot and then he's trying to stand up
again do you see I'll go back and what
you want to do instead instead of trying
to force this hand when he tries to
stand up again you going over here so
we'll go back
home yeah you see how desperate
palliative okay
prioritize that over is our manipulation
franchise this okay and when you take
that step you see I don't have to turn
his hand his hands right there his hands
already there that just goes here and
then he does get up but he runs into the
Mikio DC so this takes no one's strong
enough everything is just faked like
he'll go sweetheart
untwist your and I could do to me right
right because the thumbs a weak point
type all right so I know a lot of twist
his arm I just wanted to go right there
alright I move myself to where your hind
this right and then it reinforces that
weak point which is a thumb so we go
back and he steps into it
Oh
[Music]
to pull it out
we watch the anxiety of life Moonbeam so
I can't release let it happen can't lay
down the devote it just makes you care
live
and you're feeling the yen and young
that you're filling the holes with okay